so increasingly political difference is
a deal breaker especially for women this
will report out 86 percent think that it
has grown more difficult to date someone
who supports the opposing political
party in recent years this according to
a 2020 yougov Economist poll more than
half of men said they would date someone
with different views whereas only 35
percent of women said that they would
date someone with opposing views 48
percent of Republicans said they would
date someone with opposing views because
we're rather tolerant 49 of Independents
said the same thing only 40 percent of
Democrats said they would date a
republican everyone's focusing on this
as it pertains to politics but I
actually don't think that politics is
the big issue in this story I think
dating is the big issue specifically I
think marriage is the big issue way to
explain those numbers is to point to how
late people are getting married